olá a todos o pessoal daqui que fala e
rodar que sejam muito bem jamais um
vídeo e o estrago de que o fight night é
fredes que é um jogo pessoal muito
assustador mesmo voz e ultimamente tem
recomendado muita gente ouviu fui ver do
que este que se tratava realmente é
muito bom por isso por lá então dar um
milgare pessoal o que motiva ver eu
simplesmente ver como funcionava o jogo
seja nós temos que conseguir escapar dos
bonecos utilizando as luzes e as portas
e as câmeras eu só vi isso não quis
falar muito mas vamos lá então o que
interessa pessoal vamos lá jogar em ok e
e e pronto
gastar o meu pc trabalhava e não é só
você e eu sei que este momento muito
medo só pelo facto de ter bilhete ou
mario metas ao alto é que eu e não sei
que aquilo é mais um boneco é muito
forte inimigo porque estão fora por
cartão de crédito fone e microfone
aí eu pensei sim em cima aí pronto é o
que ela é
e olha ai pessoal lá que estão os lusos
e esta foi a única parte que eu vi do
jogo que nós temos luz temos portas para
nós conseguir esconder dos monstros como
quando eu cheguei ao pé de nós que aqui
embaixo nós temos as nossas câmeras que
vamos agora três salas para receber um
de cujos bits tal não a receberam da
questão porque é que não há nada que
também está tudo normal e também e nós
estamos aqui nesta sala onde dirige eo
por isso eles começarem aproxima muito
da nossa sala nós temos que ter mais
cuidado em
o cartola ser isto é protestante
implementar isso no meu eu não sei por
que tá aqui uma porta aberta mas tudo
bem
ok eu ainda tô aqui todos estão aqui
todos os bonecos por isso eu acho que
não há movimentações suspeitas
eu vou ficar aqui nunca tinha à espera
só que é pra não gastar muita bateria
ok sob esse ataque o guarani é um pronto
tá tudo bom para o bom é está tudo
normal ainda nava do suspeito e não sei
porque é que esta câmara não da imagem
apenas da áudio alguém partiu assim ok
nada perto da minha sala eu acho que o
pato curso e este é mais um rosto não
sei o que é que esta acção quase igual
assim a cair
está tudo normal eu não sei se é que
alguma coisa dentro assim como 20 mil
alerta agora aqui mas pronto 11 ganha o
senhor aranha é visão quando chegarem
manuel mãe está tudo bem por aqui vamos
lá ver as câmeras outra vez nada de
suspeito autor fora do rock
ali uma luta buscar meu eu não sei se
isto já estava aqui a simples cara mas
ok posso ter muito bizarra e nada de
suspeito ainda está bem aquém de serviço
ainda são duas da manhã
eu não sei qual o perfil do preso estava
aqui uns emanuel estava que o coelho
curso na tac tac tac europa avançar só
eu já tava com está a avançar
nós temos que ter cuidado nós não
podemos deixar que eu eu e vavá o nosso
quarto o pai está aqui eu só que nós
temos com 63% bateria vamos ter que
guardar um bocadinho só pela não se está
todo lá ok porque diz é o sexto andar a
câmera vocês contam ver as câmeras é
gasto mais bateria porque aparece lyoto
pausa em ver que aqui só tem um pauzinho
logo estão a gastar pouco pausini no
ataque então né
eu sei que vocês pensaram nisso ok é e
agora vamos ficar aqui à espera que o
avanço do mar e ainda está aqui caí de
joelhos outras câmeras pode ser que haja
mais bicho aqui espalhados nem sair a pé
e pronto esta não consigo perceber se
também aquela câmera não dava imagem de
uma imagem
já na próxima prova ou cá meu filho lê
não sei do leão da catraca na capital da
catalunha total de cantar e cantar no
local que o peru quarta não nos tops do
quarto oca ou totalmente você imagina
o ataque não foi calma como eu sou
campeão
a cantar não pode acontecer aqui como
pode a partir de cantar eu te amo estar
aqui e aqui estou eu acho que o edson
sombra de lula
só ela seja ouvida e 18 21 pipocam 13
foi que horas devem é 3 também é que a
hora é de que há vu
não acho que as três de 30 uma coisa
assim o espetáculo só esta hora mais
perigosa é mais perigosa ainda está aqui
há mais aquela mata escura e tem bateria
que não vai estar em estudo agora e aí
nós vamos ter aqui tem são só as portas
por mal chegou ao pé da porta nós temos
que fechar as portas
ae deixe de seu ataque ainda era
alcoólatra da câmera é só querer ainda
está aqui ele não está aqui
utilizar mais algum bicho por perto oque
eu acho que é tranqüilo por agora eu
acho que sim
pra mim é melhor né
é melhor não é
anda feito em aço do mundo
ai calma só comia câmera suíça como foi
esse período aqui tá aonde a onda não tá
mundo eu já passei o capitão na porta
o também português não de cantar eu
desaparecer o meu perfil não é preciso o
condutor do carro não está aqui está
aqui por um bom tempo
o gol empolgou de cantar e cantar
fala sério e chinelo investimento em
educação mec
muito me deixou bastante esperançoso com
uma câmera kodak calma calma calma tá
perto e está muito perto e está muito
perto de voltar ao time
a câmera 4 não é na 4a ok não se quer um
time mais para frente eu cheguei só
perdi minha resposta mente que eu não
era o coelho pede passagem que meu o
kingdom esperando o coelho e quatro
atrás de mim é isso toque com dois atrás
de mim mel já na primeira noite como é
que é possível o k4 também edson quatro
da manhã
eu não sei que horas é que isto vai mas
espero que cada empresa e não é também
começar a ficar devia à 7 8 da manhã por
isso
espero que o advogado fique devia muito
rápido ok eu só consegui ver a equipe de
maranello eu já não sei nem cantou
coelho e eu tô aqui tá na câmera trecho
aí está na casa de banho estava na casa
de banho acho é o é uma é um espaço de
informações e é isso que eu tô com 28%
bateria não posso usar muito mais as
câmeras se não eu vou ficar sem bateria
e isso não pode acontecer
o fato ainda está aqui o pato no ataque
por semana usando o tac
você não está a cargo de manuel calma e
voltou pouco dow caiu faltou um pouco de
dor e está cada vez mais perto na
calcinha 44 natal e gravo aqui no ataque
vamos esperar mais um pouco só não posso
gastar tanto dinheiro teria saído da
pista amarela não quer até agora a
câmara
pronto os russos por enquanto
por favor ajudem a ajuda de empregados
vamos cooperar com a causa
eu não gosto nunca gostei do next puxa
eu nunca gostei
o empate aqui um partido que está onde
está onde está aqui
o fato de não tocar aqui deste lado da
que está no catar pode ser o do linhão
ok está no corredor e está no corredor
da radioshack o quarto 1 mil para tocar
lex leite e não de maneira tão baixo
como na época da manhã já possamos noite
eu acho que não achei também já fica dia
algum shishin segunda noite pessoal
segundo furquim noite
então é isso só mas não quis ficar
porque com este episódio já sabem se
quiserem vir a segunda noite e mais
noite e deixou suportar este é o vosso
aic favorito porque isso é muito
importante
e fiquem bem e até a próxima
[Música]
ae
[Aplausos]
[Música]